les nouveaux plans poids du gouvernement
sur le terrain en direct les réactions
du syndicat des chômeurs et des chefs
d'entreprise
manifestation monstre contre l'apartheid
en afrique du sud la première marche
autorisée par le gouvernement
rassemblent au caf plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes
monseigneur blême récidive pourquoi
respecter un accord injuste dit il à
propos du carmel d'auschwitz pour
freiner le cancer du sein une expérience
européenne à strasbourg
le dépistage systématique et gratuit
mais monsieur bonsoir question allez
vous craquer sur le caleçon le t-shirt
ou le porte-clés batman l'homme chauve
souris s'est posé sur la france
aujourd'hui en tout cas sur ses écrans
cinéma et la batman y frappe fort
quelques 300 objets jaunes et noires
fabriquées sous licence à la mesure sans
doute du budget colossal de ce film de
son colossal succès aux états unis et du
colossal budget de publicité qui
accompagne son lancement la batman y
frappe fort et elle frappe au sommet
c'est ce qu'ont vérifier tout à l'heure
vincent gerard et philipp péter
apparemment tout est normal à l'elysée
labat magna n'a pas encore frappé
apparemment seulement le seul mini est
ce que vous allez jour de la sortie de
batman la sortie de batman douillet je
veux pas faire et la rentrée des écoles
et la sortie de batman une question une
question sur batman dans la cour de
l'elysée ah bon je veux bien batman a
donc frappé et qui plus est divise la
preuve
mesdames tasca les traits sont allés
vous voir le film mais dès que j'en ai
le temps n'est pas d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout non non non monsieur
charasse n'ira pas monsieur bérégovoy
non plus mais il ya le fan-club de c'est
que les jeunes en raffolent et j'aurais
peut-être l'impression de rajeunir
madame avis ne tient déjà plus en place
si mes enfants n'ont pas été le voir
sans moi que je serais peut-être le voir
avec eux parce que c'est la seule façon
pour moi d'oser aller voir oui il y at
il quelqu'un au gouvernement qui serait
prêt à tenir le rôle le premier ministre
fera ce soir le fera mieux que je ne
saurais le faire
dépité monsieur soissons est reparti à
ces tristes dans sa batmobile personnel
nous sommes tous de grands enfants en
belgique la polémique fait rage parce
que le film a été interdit aux moins de
16 ans batman rocard pardon le premier
ministre le premier ministre a donc
présenté officiellement ce matin le
nouveau plan de son gouvernement pour
l'emploi et il a longuement expliqué cet
après midi aux assises de la formation
professionnelle premier souci les
chômeurs de longue durée les quelques
200000 français sans emploi depuis trois
ans ou plus ne laisser personne sur le
bord du chemin juste ici à soi seul la
priorité gouvernementale pour l'emploi
une croissance économique plus soutenue
que prévu en 1988 et 4989 devrait
permettre la création d'environ 250
mille emplois cette année un peu moins
mais tout de même du plus déjà l'année
précédente et entraîné un léger recul du
chômage
mais si le tour du chômage est passé en
deux ans de 10,6 pour cent de la
population active à 9,6 pour cent ce
même population actes et cela ne se vit
pas entamer sérieusement notre
préoccupation qui reste entière comment
accepter que près d'un travailleur sur
dix demeure au bout aujourd'hui privés
d'emploi là est bien la pire des
inégalités pourquoi changer un plan qui
gagne et qui a créé en un an 250 mille
emplois affirme par ailleurs le premier
ministre le plan 89 précise donc celui
de 88
gérard decleir vous nous en rappeler les
grandes lignes il y a trois volets dans
ce plan le premier c'est l'abaissement
des charges pour inciter les entreprises
à embaucher ceux de trois façons la
réduction et le déplafonnement des
cotisations familiales et accidents du
travail
l'exonération totale des cotisations
patronales pour la première embauche
et puis il ya la baisse de 2 % de
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
bénéfices réinvestis
le deuxième volet c'est l'aménagement du
temps de travail avec d'une part la
pénalisation des heures supplémentaires
par l'obligation d'un repos compensateur
intégral et d'autre part l'incitation à
la réduction du temps de travail par des
crédits d'impôts
troisième volet une meilleure insertion
des chômeurs les tuk disparaissent au
profit de véritables
trad travail payé à la moitié du smic et
puis on simplifie et on améliore les
aides à la formation et à l'insertion
des chômeurs de longue durée le coût de
toutes ces mesures une bonne dizaine de
milliards
gérard et les réactions des partenaires
sociaux sont plutôt mitigés nous vous le
disions dès hier soir
alors comment réagit-on plus près du
terrain avec nous en direct deux hommes
aux préoccupations différentes et qui
pourraient être complémentaires vous
monsieur dubois vous êtes chef
d'entreprise vous dirigez une affaire
d'imprimerie de sérigraphie plus
précisément et vous monsieur paga vous
avez créé il ya quelques années le
syndicat des chômeurs la première
question vous revient le plan rocard 89
vous paraît-il plus efficace que le
précédent
oui il y a manifestement des aspects
nouveaux est positif dans le plan à
rocard et je m'en réjouis mais j'ai peur
quand même que ce ne soit pas à la
hauteur du drame des chemins de longue
durée
vous l'avez rappelé gérard le gall avait
tout à l'heure neuf cent mille chômeurs
de longue durée
deux cent mille de plus + 3 ans et parmi
eux 500 milles qui touche une indemnité
de 200 de 2000 francs oui et justement
monsieur bagaya le traitement économique
de chômage est aussi la manière dont la
société tolère au rejette ou au
contraire acceptent ces chômeurs à votre
avis à la lumière de votre expérience et
ce que la société française a fait des
progrès dans ce sens il y à quelques
progrès mais ils sont ils sont très très
léger car s'il y avait eu des progrès
décisifs il y aura bien longtemps qu'on
aurait pu résoudre le chômage de longue
durée
mais c'est le triomphe des corporatismes
et des égoïsmes qui ont empêché cette
solution il y à un effort considérable à
faire pour rattraper tout le retard et
il a des mesures plus plus important
plus audacieuses qu'il faut préconiser
et notamment il faut aller au delà des
propositions de duc lamothe
en ce qui concerne la réduction du temps
de travail la réduction de notre oeil
est un élément décisif et c'est d'un
paquetage des emplois et cela suppose
des mesures de l'ordre par exemple les
35 heures de travail par semaine
monsieur paquet a fondamentalement
comment expliquez vous que les chômeurs
de long
durée n'est pas profité de
l'amélioration de l'emploi des 250 mille
emplois qui ont été créés depuis un an
et bien c'est à la fois tout le problème
est le drame car en effet la priorité
des priorités aurait été de faire
bénéficier les chômeurs de longue durée
des dividendes de la reprise de la
croissance
et on voit à l'heure actuelle les
organisations syndicales réclament et
pour toute une série de catégories de
salariés
il va y avoir peut-être des
manifestations ou à des grèves
or que la priorité des priorités ce
devrait être pour les chômeurs de longue
durée d'abord le rad l'ordonnait unanime
isation correct encore une fois on ne
peut pas vivre avec 2000 francs par mois
et puis oui monsieur bagages nous
interrompt parce que monsieur dubois
donc est il n'est pas au mans comme vous
il est il est à à boulogne il est en
direct aussi avec nous monsieur dubois
vous vous dites que vous ne trouvez pas
assez de main d'oeuvre spécialisée ce
que vous seriez prêt à embaucher un
chômeur de longue durée maintenant que
vous connaissez plan du gouvernement il
y à de nouveaux allègements de charges
vous ne perdiez pas de charges
patronales pendant plusieurs mois
si c'était le cas bon écoute et je crois
que le problème n'est peut-être pas
aussi simple en vérité aujourd'hui je
pense que la machine économique tourne
bien les entreprises tournent
parfaitement bien la situation
économique est bonne mon ultime
production tourne parfaitement mon gros
problème c'est que je ne trouve pas de
personnel qualifié et ça je crois que
c'est un c'est un drame
on a en france un problème de formation
à tel point qu'on envisage l'autre la
profession envisage de faire une école
une école de sérigraphie tout simplement
pour trouver du personnel qualifié et je
crois que le problème du chômage est
avant tout un problème de formation
messieurs du coup on a quand même envie
de vous dire en multi multiplier les
heures supplémentaires plutôt
qu'embaucher ce que c'est pas quand même
pour vous un peu la solution de facilité
celle qui coûte le moins cher pas écouté
je crois que ça n'a rien à voir
les heures supplémentaires on est obligé
de faire on est obligés nous
dans notre entreprise de faire face à
des à coups qu'on ne peut régler que par
des heures supplémentaires et je pense
que je ne verrai pas mon personnel avec
du personnel supplémentaire non
qualifiés je pense que ça n'est pas
possible
il est absolument indispensable de
conserver cette souplesse qu'on a si on
veut conserver notre compétitivité
notre problème c'est la qualification à
le problème c'est la qualification et la
formation des personnels ça c'est clair
le plan en choeur veut inciter les
entreprises à réduire le temps de
travail à mieux utiliser les machines et
ainsi donc à embaucher ce que ça vous
paraît une bonne idée alors je pense que
utilisent mieux utiliser les machines ça
me parait effectivement être une bonne
chose mais réduire ou limiter les heures
supplémentaires ça ne me paraît pas être
une bonne chose mais ce que ce sens là
on peut embaucher
ben je crois que non le problème est
qu'en est encore lié à la formation si
on ne trouve pas personnel qualifié on
sera obligé avec le personnel qu'on a
formé le personnel très compétent
là on sera obligé de faire des heures
supplémentaires alors monsieur magadan
vos fichiers vous n'avez personne
adressée à monsieur dubois
écoutez monsieur dubois vient de poser
un problème
en effet est fondamental c'est vrai que
l'on ne forme pas à l'université dans
les écoles pour les métiers qui existent
aujourd'hui ou qui existeront demain en
forme parfois pour des métiers
disparaissent ou qui vont disparaître
alors ça c'est un problème de
l'université de notre système
d'enseignement il ya des réformes la
faire et ensuite il faut bien voir que
des chômeurs de longue durée sont
souvent des gens qui n'ont qu'ils n'ont
pas en effet de grandes qualification et
le problème c'est peut-être faire preuve
d'imagination on ne verra peut-être pas
suffisamment dans les entreprises
classiques des emplois pour eux alors il
ya d'autres secteurs le secteur de
l'économie alternative de l'économie
sociale on peut imaginer beaucoup de
choses dont vous savez nous faisons nous
ici par exemple dans la sarthe
des sortes d'expérimentations sociale où
nous accueillons les jeunes tubes des
chômeurs de longue durée dans des
secteurs nouveaux de protection de la
nature d'aménagement des rivières de et
cetera et c'est là où il ya des choses
importantes à faire il faut faire preuve
d'imagination et ne pas vouloir à tout
prix créer des emplois de loin on ne
peut plus ancrée monsieur dubois
monsieur paga je vous remercie il est
évident que le problème du chômage va
continuer à préoccuper les partenaires
sociaux le gouvernement et surtout sur
le terrain
des chefs d'entreprise est aussi les
gens qui se préoccupent dont du problème
humain du chômage en tout cas à partir
de demain
le premier ministre lui va rencontrer
les partenaires sociaux cette fois pour
plaider la cause du pacte de croissance
autrement dit les règles de
redistribution des bénéfices de
l'expansion et la partie là non plus ne
sera pas facile
la direction de peugeot mulhouse a
accepté ce soir de négocier avec les
syndicats qui maintiennent pourtant leur
mot d'ordre de grève aujourd'hui le
conflit s'était durci et avait gagné ce
show sur place se fige ouvre frédéric
basket c'est le berceau de peugeot est
fabriquée la 605 qui bascule à son tour
dans la grève à sochaux la production
est fortement perturbée des débrayages
ont eu lieu toute la journée
la tension est montée d'une manière s'il
est sensible mais important depuis
vendredi
cette compétition est difficile à
l'heure actuelle de connaître le nombre
exact de grévistes mais à mulhouse ils
sont environ 3000 et leur détermination
à monter d'un cran
on nous dit de faire des efforts et des
efforts et puis quand j'ai plus tard eux
benoît quelque chose après et jusqu'à
maintenant c'est lui tant passée que
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a rien du dos et
les cadences bombe a frappé par une fois
un certain flottement règne dans les
rangs des non grévistes
si pour eux il n'est pas question de
faire grève et revendications des
ouvriers de peugeot
leur part est souvent justifiée moi je
suis d'accord avec eux
mais j'ai une famille où j'ai nourri
chez 3 enfants qui sont en bas âge j'ai
une femme qui travaille pas pour rénover
son expansion il n'y a aucun raison de
cassé la boîte c'est impossible à laon
et remis en 92 montpon qui gagne c'est
pas comme ça qu'on y arrive c'est non
grévistes sont encadrés par des agents
de maîtrise recruter et badger par la
direction
un rôle très mal acceptée par les
grévistes insultes et bousculades se
multiplient
l'atmosphère ne cesse de s'alourdir
parmi les ouvriers du conte peugeot
l'étranger maintenant pour tous ceux qui
en afrique du sud et ailleurs lutte
contre l'apartheid
la date est sans doute historique au cap
aujourd'hui dans la ville ensanglanté
lors des dernières élections
des milliers de personnes ont participé
à la première manifestation contre la
ségrégation
la première manifestation autorisée par
le régime sud africain sur place martine
laroche-joubert alain st une véritable
onde de choc
la première manifestation autorisée
depuis trente ans en afrique du sud
nous avons vu aujourd'hui inimaginable
il ya quelques jours à peine la ville du
cap
une ville blanche traversée par cette
marche noire plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes
fort qu'une présence policière kulen
quelque peu surpris les plans
conduite par l'archevêque anglican
desmond tout et le maire blanc de la
ville du cap
une marche sans incident à les presser
tu as plus considérable et après le
service d'or est parfaitement organisé
et maintenant du balcon de la mairie à
notre choc
surprenant le maire du cap un blanc qui
a rentré semble lui souhaite
l'amour la paix et la fin de la
discrimination raciale
enfin le défi ultime l'étendard de la
haine c'est le mouvement anti apartheid
est accrochée sur ce balcon
puis 17 la place à l'archevêque anglican
desmond tutu et effet aujourd'hui est un
jour de victoire c'est la victoire du
bon sens la victoire de notre peuple
la victoire de la paix nous devrions
accepter monsieur déclaré mme migiro et
l'eau
vous vouliez savoir si nous étions
capables d'être pacifique et bien je
venais voir vous même
cette marche est d'abord vous formidable
victoire pour la communauté noire
mais si ces politiques pour frederik de
klerk fait le début de son mandat a fait
sa marque
c'était libéral en tout cas pour le
moment dans un pays voisin en namibie
assassinats de dirigeants blanc qui
mouvement nationaliste noir le swapo
anton lui bove qui un avocat de 37 ans a
été abattu sans doute par l'extrême
droite
un assassinat absurde déclare le
ministre sud africain des affaires
étrangères
la namibie vous le savez se dégage
lentement sous la houlette des nations
unies du protectorat sud africain
pourquoi respecter un accord que l'on a
signé quand il n'est pas juste c'est au
nom d'une logique pour le moins
subjective que le primatologue monsignor
games a ravivé aujourd'hui la polémique
sur le carmel d'auschwitz
s'adressant à des théologiens peu le nez
à lublin il a remis en cause encore une
fois l'accord signé en février 87 à
genève par quatre cardinaux et quatre
représentants des institutions juives
michel mompontet les carmélites
d'auschwitz ne partiront pas disait le 3
septembre dernier monseigneur glem moins
de quinze jours après avoir suscité un
tollé dans la communauté juive mondiale
pour des propos jugés antisémites
le primate pologne persiste et signe
l'église ne doit pas se sentir obligé de
respecter l'accord de genève à auschwitz
on ne peut pas parler de transfert mais
d'expulsion c'est une atteinte à la
dignité des carmélites en ayant une
nouvelle fois le bien-fondé les accords
de genève de 1987 prévoyant le
déplacement de quelques centaines de
mètres de ce qu armel monseigneur glem
continue d'aller à l'encontre d'un texte
est signé pourtant par quatre cardinaux
dont monseigneur lustiger et monseigneur
de courtrai le vatican n'a toujours pas
aujourd'hui donner officiellement sa
position
le carmel d'auschwitz est pourtant situé
sur un site classé patrimoine mondial
par l'unesco
l'exode de réfugiés stalmans s'est un
peu ralenti aujourd'hui de la hongrie à
l'allemagne fédérale mais c'est sur le
plan diplomatique que la situation se
crispe la tchécoslovaquie et la roumanie
appuyez bruyamment l'allemagne de l'est
la hongrie envoie des émissaires à
berlin-est et à moscou où sont par
ailleurs réunis les vice ministres des
affaires étrangères du pacte de varsovie
le grand bond en arrière c'est le thème
du magazine résistance consacré à la
chine
vous pourrez le suivre ce soir à 22h15
sur antenne 2 pour noël mamère une
journaliste camille aurel appelant
destinant parcouru le coeur de la chine
4000 km en trois semaines et quelque
part dans le sud
cette brève rencontre comme un signe
d'espoir étudiante dans une université
province
elle était à pékin pour soutenir ceux de
la place tiananmen au lendemain du 4
juin elle a pu échapper au coup de filet
dans la gare de pékin depuis elle
parcourt la campagne chinoise faisant à
sa façon la longue marche avec cette
espèce de fascination pour mao qui dort
dans le coeur de tous les chinois elle
nous compris les leaders étudiants
n'auraient pas dû partir il aurait dû
aller dans les campagnes pour parler aux
paysans de village en village
elle cherche la conscience politique de
la chine quand tu vois ça c'est un livre
qui enseigne à porter juste
elle du gouvernement premier jour de la
rentrée des classes
les paysans n'envoient pas leurs enfants
à l'école avec enthousiasme 40 millions
d'enfants entre 7 et 14 ans ne seraient
pas scolarisés
c'est un livre de science ses villas
c'est un livre pour la pensée mon
histoire de carnas un squelette et
étudiants et d'inscription et dans
toutes les écoles dans toutes les
universités espoirs ouverture du coeur
futur obéissance et bien sur
l'obéissance vous appelle pas en quoi
je ne sais pas non à tout citoyen j'ai
entendu à la radio oui on en parle et sa
mythique qu'est ce que tu en penses
je trouve qu'il fallait faire de
l'étudiant ou du gouvernement j'ai une
gueule sont les étudiants qui devaient
le faire
je vais te dire pourquoi je réagis comme
ça je suis étudiante chinoise
je n'ai rencontré que platine est dit
que les étudiants en rayon des ondes
22h15 résistance consacré à la chine
tout à l'heure le maire de new york le
prochain ne sera élu que dans deux mois
mais on connaît depuis la nuit dernière
le nom des deux candidats qui vont
s'affronter en consignes et edward koch
maire sortant de new york ne se
représentera pas aux élections du 7
novembre prochain l'investiture
démocrate revient à devil kings queens
s'ils étaient élus dit lui qu'il serait
le premier maire noir de new york
face à lui rudolph giuliani candidats
république edouard koch concouraient
pour son quatrième mandat mais new york
qu'il est là sa réputation de briseuse
de carrière ne lui aura pas permis de
battre le record de longévité
nouvelle péripétie le procédures dans le
procès de l'amoco kabylie le juge mme
akar annuler sa décision d'accorder 60
millions de francs aux ostréiculteurs
bretons parce que l'état français les a
déjà indemnisé et que amoco à rembourser
l'état
réponse les bretons cette indemnisation
d'urgence ne faudrait pas le manque à
gagner
l'annulation du juge si elle était
confirmée aurait surtout pour effet de
retarder encore le remboursement
nouvelles méthodes pour le kgb de la
glace nost les services secrets
soviétiques présent aujourd'hui à la
presse un film sur leur activité
exemple sur ces images la découverte de
documents chez un couple d'espions
le général jeannou lacaze ancien chef
d'état-major des armées devrait annoncer
demain son adhésion au cni le centre
national des indépendants jeannou lacaze
de députés européens il essaie septième
sur la liste udf fr lors des dernières
élections
l'émission de neuf maires du morbihan
geste de solidarité avec yves rocher
l'industriel inculpé hier sur une
plainte de la pnp dans la sphère du
rachat de l'entreprise petit bateau
trois morts un blessé en réanimation
bilan de l'incendié qui a ravagé la nuit
dernière une maison d'accueil pour
personnes âgées près de quimper
le sinistre a sans doute été provoquée
fin l'implosion d'un téléviseur
le feu a été rapidement circonscrit mais
ce sont les fumées toxiques qui explique
selon bilan
légère hausse de l'indicateur de
tendance à la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui +0 23% relative stabilité du
dollar à 6 francs 64 30 au cours
officiel
oui et puis un espoir depuis tout à
l'heure si vous êtes chômeur et si vous
êtes de viseur en sérigraphie depuis le
dialogue que vous avez suivi dans dans
ce journal en direct entre monsieur paga
le président du syndicat des chômeurs et
monsieur dubois qui a donc une
entreprise de sérigraphie bien monsieur
dubois nous dit qu'ils cherchent de
viseur en sérigraphie l'a donc un emploi
a proposé
si vous êtes donc dans ce cas voici le
numéro téléphone à orléans où vous
pouvez le contacter c'est le 38 66 20 58
30 38 66 20 58 un deviseur donc en
sérigraphie de l'espoir aussi pour
daniel gilbert elle pourrait sortir de
prison demain le parquet de grasse a
requis sa mise en liberté avec une
caution d'un million de francs le cancer
du sein continue de faire des ravages
même si on le guérit de mieux en mieux
25 mille nouveaux cas par an en france
il faut donc systématiser le dépistage
c'est le sens de l'expérience mise en
oeuvre à strasbourg sous l'égide de la
communauté européenne
jean daniel flaysakier frédéric bazille
appareil sert à faire des mammographies
c'est à dire des radiographies du sein
un examen qui devrait prochainement
faire partie des habitudes de vie pour
les femmes comme le sont déjà la visite
chez le dentiste ou le médecin
c'est en effet la meilleure arme pour
prévenir et dépister suffisamment tôt
l'existence d'un cancer du sein cancer
le plus fréquent et le plus meurtrier
aussi chez les femmes pour montrer que
ce dépistage est non seulement faisable
mais aussi rentable radiologue
hospitalier radiologue de ville ont uni
leurs efforts à strasbourg depuis le 15
mai il propose à toutes les femmes de 50
à 65 ans de venir subir cet examen en
quelque sorte gratuitement puisque c'est
la sécurité sociale qui en assument les
frais une expérience unique en france et
en europe
mené avec une très grande rigueur
ainsi les clichés sont ils eu deux fois
avoir trois fois même une première fois
par le radiologue qui a fait l'examen
une deuxième fois systématiquement par
un spécialiste différents une troisième
fois enfin si les deux premiers lecteurs
ont eu des avis divergents
si tout est normal la mammographie sur
la fête de façon routinière tous les
deux ans mais entre temps le médecin
traitant et la femme auront aussi un
rôle à jouer
il est très important que les femmes
continuent à examiner
soto palper les seins entre les valves
et davy sa jambe au graphique
ceci bien sûr à condition qu' elles
l'apprennent par leur médecin traitant
ce soit le généraliste gynécologue et
non pas par des dépliants c'est
difficile d'apprendre se palper les
autos palpation examen par le médecin
mammographie tous les deux ans les
femmes ont aujourd'hui toutes les armes
pour lutter contre un fléau auquel elle
paye un trop lourd tribut vingt-cinq
mille nouveaux cas par an et une
fréquence qui ne cesse d'augmenter
et puis cette mise en garde que l'on
peut lire dans un très sérieux journal
britannique mise en garde adressée aux
automobilistes ne vous mettez pas les
doigts dans le nez aux feux rouges
journal décrit le cas de ce malheureux
dans la voiture a été percutée par
l'arrière alors qu'il se livrait à cette
intéressante exercice il s'est rompu une
artère du nez il s'est évanoui et les
médecins n'ont compris le lien entre le
choc banal et l'importance de
l'hémorragie que bien plus tard la
contrefaçon découvre de nouveaux
terrains après les faux vuitton les faux
quartier voici les faux logiciels
la police en a saisi 2000 hier à paris
fils boisserie et noël alexandre nous
explique cette affaire qui inquiète les
accros de l'ordinateur
il connaissait déjà les pirates
maintenant voilà les faussaires disque
est dupliquée manuel et coffrets
purement et simplement copiés ce faux
logiciels étaient ensuite distribués
dans les magasins spécialisés les
grandes surfaces c'est une entreprise
ayant pignon sur rue qui s'est livré à
ce trafic
la société wings a diffusé plusieurs
milliers d'exemplaires contrefaits avec
un bénéfice de 600 francs par logiciel
le butin s'élèverait à plus de 2
millions de francs un préjudice bien
plus importants pour digital reasearch
egée est et software les deux sociétés
victimes qui affronte la un genre inédit
d'escroquerie parce que maintenant on
avait assisté à des affaires célèbres de
piratage de copies de logiciels cette
chose de connu des tas de gens le font
jusqu'à maintenant on n'avait jamais
assisté à la contrefaçon c'est une
différence importante c'est un pas de
plus qui est franchie dans le domaine de
la violation des droits une société pour
détecter la supercherie il suffit de
regarder la boîte le vrai logiciel de
publication assistée par ordinateur
times works comporte une étiquette
bordeaux frappé d'un numéro l'autre n'en
a pas le faussaire n'est jamais tout à
fait parfait de mots de sport passons
vite sur le football avec le pénible
match nul obtenu par paris saint germain
face au phanar d un match comptant pour
les troupes de l'uefa 0 1 0
revenons-en à la natation et saluant un
revenant un vieillard de 39 ans qui veut
refaire de la compétition
son nom mark spitz noël mamère marche
pitt remet en pratique sur la plus haute
marche du podium aux jeux de barcelone
c'est le pari un peu insensé qu'il vient
de lancer à près de 39 ans le papillon
de l'année 1972 a encore soif de
médailles aux jeux de munich
il réalise pourtant un exploit toujours
inégalé remporté sept médailles d'or 4
individuelles et deux en relais
à 22 ans au sommet de son art spitz
domine alors en nage libre en papillon à
tel point que les temps réalisés à
l'époque lui aurait permis d'être encore
champion olympique en 76 et en 81 il
aurait cependant terminé huitième et
dernier de la finale de séoul l'année
dernière à plus d'une seconde du
vainqueur
spitz estime pourtant capable de revenir
il ne s'alignera que dans le 100 m
papillon son style préféré
là où il pense encore progresser
s'il se qualifie pour barcelone et
remporte sa 10e médaille d'or de à
mexico et 7 à munich marche put nageurs
asthmatique et âgé alors de 42 ans
mériterait pour lui tout seul une page
entière dans le livre olympique il ya
des espoirs toujours jeune noir cabrol
mark spitz socialiste des papillons
météo demain on va impressionner
voilà non c'est à dire que demain en
fait nous allons assister à d'abord une
passe et d'humidité et d'orages c'est
vrai et ensuite le retour du soleil
c'est bon parce que le soleil revient
pour le week-end samedi et dimanche
seront deux belles journées et humilité
plus chaleur c'est très bon pour les
champignons
ah voilà une bonne nouvelle vous en
dirai plus tout à l'heure - je vous
donne encore les pronostics de pierre de
bresse pour le tiercé et le quarté de
vincennes demain le il ya dix-huit
partants donc les favorites et redresse
le 13 le 15 le 18 17 le 12 le 11 et le 8
1 non partant le 19
voilà dernier journal à 23h30 avec henri
sannier demain comme tous les matins à
partir de 6h30 télématin avec mady tran
et gérard morin très bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain 20 heures